The Country Where Its Tradition to Have Kentucky
Fried Chicken for Christmas
Kentucky Fried Chicken is hardly considered
a suitable place to get one’s food for a
traditional Christmas meal in most parts of
the world.
There is one exception, though.
In Japan, it is a Christmas tradition to order
KFC.
So how exactly did Christmas, the celebration
of the birth of Jesus Christ, become synonymous
with a bucket of fried chicken in the land
of the rising sun?
Well for one, Christmas wasn’t really celebrated
at all historically in Japan and has only
relatively recently been adopted.
The Japanese predominantly followed the Buddhism
and Shinto religions, so Christmas was essentially
adopted from the West and holds little religious
significance to many Japanese, even today.
In fact, Christianity was actually banned
throughout Japan in the 1600s and continued
to be so until the mid 1800s.
However, during this period, a small enclave
group of Japanese Christians, known as ‘Kakure
Kirishitan’ (“hidden Christians”) continued
the missionary work of Saint Francis Xavier
who arrived in Japan in 1549.
The religion, along with Christmas, reemerged
somewhere between 1868 and 1912.
It wasn’t long after that many Japanese
started to mirror Western Christmas traditions
like exchanging gifts, decorating trees, putting
up lights, etc, even though it was not a national
holiday in Japan.
So where did KFC come in?
According to KFC, this particular unusual
Christmas tradition is said to date back to
the 1970s when supposedly a customer at the
chain’s Aoyama store observed that, in a
land bereft of the customary turkey for a
celebratory dinner, fried chicken was the
next best thing.
christmas-japanThis idea eventually percolated
up to the corporate offices of KFC and prompted
the company to start a huge advertising campaign
in Japan called “Kurisumasu ni wa kentakkii!”
(Kentucky for Christmas!) in 1974, which became
ludicrously popular thanks to this campaign
and the popularity of American culture in
Japan at the time.
KFC has milked this Christmas tradition in
the country ever since, and even portrays
their founder and well known icon, Colonel
Sanders, as Father Christmas, dressing statues
of him outside every KFC in Santa suits….
Yes, Colonel Santa!
The custom of eating KFC for Christmas is
so popular in Japan that you’ll not only
see lines of people snaked outside every branch
in the country at this time, but people even
reserve their buckets of chicken well in advance
to make sure they don’t miss out.